i still can't tell when you're joking or
not
[Music]
oh
what's up everybody carlos here welcome
to our very exciting nerd alert panel
for moon knight this was going to be
like a a mid-season panel but now it's
kind of like an end of act 2 panel is
what i'm feeling based on the structure
of the story we're joined today by two
brilliant gentlemen who are ready to
talk about this show we've got jordan
calhoun who's an author editor-in-chief
at lifehacker who's got a book coming
out in like a week
called piccolo is black it's gonna be
amazing also another brilliant man ellen
abdelmade is joining us uh host of the
cbc podcast pop chat
also a writer author who has a book
coming out in may called son of
elsewhere
so i gotta up my game and start writing
something to be
considered in this panel here but we're
gonna get going with
we'll get going with moonlight first of
all this is you know we can
analyze all these different shows and
movies from all these different angles
but the first thing i want to know is
are you enjoying the show for what it is
is it entertaining for you guys this is
major spoilers for everyone watching
so if you haven't seen that
go watch it and then come back how
honest do you want me to be here
go for it go for it it's not here
because the answer for me personally is
that i am not enjoying it yet
but this is often where i sit with these
disney series on or these marvel series
on disney plus which is that they're
asking you to trust them for a certain
stretch of time the way that i feel now
is just about where i felt in the
beginning of wanda vision which i ended
up loving and the way that i felt you
know early on in hawkeye which i ended
up loving way i felt early on in a lot
of these series where they're asking you
to like give us some time we're going to
build a foundation stick with us and
it'll be worth it in the end jordan are
you a big comic book guy or not i am
because like i am not and so i come at
all of these series products from this
point of view of like
you have to win me over you have to win
me over and convince you that this
character is worth investing time
and like that's so much of what marvel's
project has been from the beginning i'm
like i am what having 25 movies deep and
five different television series deep at
this point and so every once in a while
when i'm introduced to a new character
i'm like ah i don't know who this is i
haven't read the books i'm not that
excited about what's happening here you
have to like make the case for me why i
should be excited about this and you
know what they've been successful one
hundred percent of the time that's an
interesting contrast that both of you
are are uh coming at it from because you
know
i felt the same way i think jordan that
you did i was a little bit bored off the
top kind of like okay when when is this
stuff going to kick in because i kind of
knew like for example what we see at the
end of episode four we might as well
just jump into it
i knew that there was basis for that to
be part of this series and i think i was
expecting to be part of this series i
just wanted to know how they were going
to do it
[Music]
stephen
given the whole adventure that we've
gone on in episodes one through three
and the whole raiders of the lost ark
style adventure in the first half or so
of episode four
how did you feel when we got thrown
with that reveal for the last like 10 12
minutes
it was right on pace i feel like it's
right on pace with what we've seen in
their previous series where you expect
some big twist or something to actually
hook you in in a way that the earlier
episodes did let's see how they land
this let's see how they stick the ending
and i think so much of moon knight's
big picture when it's all said and done
is going to be based on how well they
stick that landing because again right
now they're saying trust us trust us
trust us it's going to be worth it and
if they stick it then we'll say oh it
was this whole thing was worth it it was
absolutely amazing and if they don't
stick it then it's going to be really
forgettable in a way that many of us
expected going into it like even me as a
comic book person i don't care about
move night no one cares about movie
night like
and
it's it's a heat check for marvel right
there there are so many heat checks that
marvel pulls off and to elle mead's
point like you start to care about
characters that you otherwise wouldn't
have cared about no one cared about dr
strange now dr strange is a movie people
care about dr strange no one cared about
hawkeye no one cared about loki no one
cared about i mean if you think back far
enough like iron man was a sealess
character in marvel no one thinks of him
as a seedless character anymore because
marvel wrote him well enough in the mcu
to make you care right so there's so
many characters that marvel has done a
really good job writing and making you
care about them and moon knight is the
latest heat check or like ant-man for
example no one gave a damn
man right who cared about scott lang no
one thought about him until they made
him this this you know this household
character that people care about so with
moon knight i think so much of it
including this twist ending like so much
of this is is paint by the numbers fair
for disney so far there is nothing
that's been surprising for me including
the surprise itself at the end of
episode 4. the question for me is after
that
will
he end up being a character that has a
compelling story it's almost like
watching i mean like you said it like
it's like watching them stick to landing
this is acrobatic this is gymnastics so
being like we're gonna pull out this
character i'm gonna be like no way you
can make that work no way you can make
me care about this and then like the
model and it's a model has been repeated
over and over and over again is that it
is making making us all interested in
this and i just think like something
like that i mean maybe it's crude to say
from just like an entertainment business
perspective like this is some ninja
level like i am so impressed by the way
that they sort of keep applying these
frameworks to characters like like you
said like you know nobody cared about
before but now they're sort of you know
their ip that keeps on keeps on giving
you know
where's your shirt
oh well i mean if you're gonna hide it
for all eternity you'd probably put it
in a place where
the average looter wouldn't think to
look
so what do you think
maybe like the best relationship in the
show is not at all layla and stephen but
in fact it's like stephen and mark and i
would like to ship them in the way that
they hugged at the end of the episode
was so sweet and like and i didn't
expect to be saying any of this i sort
of you know i i completely expected to
have a sort of cold relationship to it
of
i would like to know what's going on
with marvel so i can sort of write about
it sometime later in the future if
there's some kind of hook um it's like
an fyi kind of relationship it's what i
thought i was in for but then here we
are i'm like i've invested in this
character i want to know what happens
next what isn't that sarcophagus what is
going on here um these are curiosities
that i have
that i would like to give marvel credit
for activating in me because i gotta
tell you i didn't think it was possible
i mean mentioned the sarcophagus there
the little shaking sarcophagus that they
didn't open at the end of that episode
uh what's in there who's in there do we
both know the answer
i don't i don't elamine said something
that actually speaks to what i'm just
realizing is my hook into moon knight
and why i'm interested in the
development of this character in the
longer scheme of the mcu which is power
levels trying to predict what like the
fan theories of it all there's going to
be a million fan theories that are going
to float around literally i avoid them i
generally do not care about the fan
theories like 99
i don't care about them most of them are
gonna be wrong and that's not where i
pull entertainment from personally why
have you ever opened write it faster bro
i've never opened write it at the end of
that
you know like i don't i don't because
what i care more about then the answer
to the question is narratively how they
give us the answer to that question i
mean you said that you hopped on reddit
super fast to figure out what people
were saying is there anything that stuck
out to you that you were like
either it makes sense to you not knowing
you know the universe that these people
know about or something that kind of
shocked you that made you go oh i want
to see if this is true
yeah i mean the the most popular most
immediately popular theory was that
sarcophagus has contained the third
alter evo a third identity for martha
stephen
and it's jake lockley i believe i read
the name
sorry to this man but i don't know this
man you know
and then the other thing was the
explanation of the of the hippo lady um
because i was like i don't i'm not well
versed in like egyptian gods um i i
don't assume anyone watching this show
is um and he was like oh this is like
the goddess of fertility why does it
help me at all so thanks a lot um
and
now i'm
more confused than i've ever been jake
lockley for those in the audience that
don't know because here's a nerd in me
coming out you know that knows what this
is
he is the third personality for these
for this trio of of mark and stephen and
jake and
in the comics to treat things
differently what something i like about
what they're doing in the mcu in general
is taking what you think you know if
you've read the comics before and going
we're going to do this with it now and
you know you kind of still respect what
it was before but you get to see our
version of this and it's going to be
awesome it'll be like a definitive
version of it so much so that it'll
affect what's written in the comics
coming after so whatever we see with
jake is probably going to be pretty cool
and that's again what you going back to
the idea of it being gymnastics this is
this is where we're on the tight rope
right now
yeah you know if it is this guy
do they stick that landing so that
enough people are satisfied by whatever
this reveal is and
by who he is compared to
mark and compared to
stephen as well i'm 100 expecting bruce
banner shows at the end of all of this
you're like you know you got something
here and i can help you with your
different identities and like let's
let's get on board and go to here and go
to new york um that's 100 what i'm
expecting i don't know if it'll come to
pass but like i don't know jordan do you
buy it you buy this oh no absolutely not
i completely agree with you and i would
even go a step further to say it's not
just far-fetched to not integrate him
into the larger mcu but it also would be
completely pointless you're a free man
and of course with that freedom
comes choice
and right now
you have a very important decision to
make
you guys are both writers and you both
have um i'm sure there are ideas in your
head although you don't want to
dive into all these theories there's got
to be an idea in your head of like where
this goes next like what we see
in episode five and to you what would be
sticking the landing oh man ellen mean
you go first you have an answer for
would be stick in the landing government
just write the rest of this series yeah
just work for it yeah
and then you'll get that disney money
afterwards
amazing wow this is a really late
occasion to invite me to the writer's
room but sure man let's break the rest
of the story
i think like in my mind um you know i
would like to see a very uh meaningful
death for arab i'm so interested in that
character and to have that payoff i
don't know what that's going to look
like but um the idea of a character
who's like obsessed with bringing good
to the world and eliminating evil um
that's like i don't think you can just
like send off that character with like a
regular you can't just battle that guy
and kill him that would that seems a
little bit silly so when we're thinking
about
carol and what happens to him in the end
here
would it be satisfying to see him
actually become
shadow knight who is like the broken
mirror image
of moon knight i continue to be the meme
of sorry to this man um but i do not
know who this man is i was like again
and i actually like i like this about
starting these new series and like i
don't know who any of these people are
or why we're here whatsoever and so uh
the idea that we could go in that
direction like that sounds like fun to
me and that would be an interesting
payoff to see it explored um but i don't
i didn't even know that that was a
possibility until now i thought you
might just like die like a regular dad
um and so i'm i'm excited to watch him
find out what happened i think it would
absolutely be meaningful and cool to
watch i love watching i think part of
the thing that does have me and a lot of
viewers hooked is the
seeing the inner turmoil between mark
and steven and to see anyone struggling
with sort of a shadow version of
themselves or a fractured version after
a death like that would make that death
so much more compelling and meaningful
and i think it would be fun to watch for
sure
do we think
do we think that harold will a
fall from a very high height
[Laughter]
b
um be impaled by a mirror
somehow
or c
ahmet comes up and eats them and
swallows them and drags them down what's
the most likely
decapitated by two moons going this way
one goes high one goes down yeah
there's
[Laughter]
i like that i like that i do like the
visualization of ahmed coming from the
ground and eating too the whole sand
swallow thing like that that hasn't been
done in this yet and there's a lot of
parts of the show that are paying homage
to
you know those cliches so i would yeah
it would be cool to see that
you could also
melt or catch fire or
any of those you know indiana jones
there's still many more days to be
exploited here yes
i like that we're doing all this work
for disney and marvel
meanwhile like kevin feige is somewhere
in hawaii to be like i'm just asking
questions and then like
before we go
i know the series is not finished yet
but i want to get a rating from both of
you
as to how far
how well you think it's been doing and
we're going to go from let's say
crescent moon to full moon
[Laughter]
where along this scale has moonlight sat
for you thus far jordan it's a half moon
right now and it cannot connect for
wayne it can whack their wane based on
what's happening
beyond this it's right now it's right on
pace and it can either stick the landing
or it can twist an ankle and we'll see
where that goes
i'm gonna give it uh one more quarter
moon than that um i would say it's a
three-quarter moon what do we call those
do they have a name
we'll call it three-quarter and i'm sure
there's a someone in the comments will
be like it's this you idiot this is what
it's called that's what i want i want
you to get at me and let me know what a
three-quarter movie is like when it's
almost a full movement it's not quite a
full move like that that that state of
mind um in the sense that i think
they've done enough to keep me curious
and keep me interested in people coming
back for the next few episodes two more
episodes left is that is that where
we're at right now
yeah yeah um i'm sold and i'm i'm gonna
continue following this character
however they got work to do they gotta
kind of finish that mood you know you
gotta you gotta you gotta give me that
last little quarter me
right on well guys thank you so much for
spending the time and talking real nerd
stuff with me today and we'll you know
we'll check back in and see if you know
to your um to your liking moonlight did
that double back tuck and actually stuck
the landing
amazing thanks for having us
thanks guys
you